[Music]
[Applause]
uh Nick Wright host of first things
first on Fox Sports One and the podcast
what's right with Nick Wright on iTunes
and YouTube Do You Remember players
getting a basketball after they've
scored their first point never heard of
it I haven't NE never heard of it
haven't either the I mean maybe we what
do you do for teams that have multiple
rookies in game one cut it in half like
like you know I was going to say like
Samson but that's his hair who's the
king the king that had to cut the baby
in half I don't remember uh I don't know
what you do so yeah I've never heard of
it also the inseason tournament final
because the inseason tournament does
count for your stats but the final
itself oddly does not because it's an
83rd game which is probably something
they need to adjust but those from a
holistic perspective are your first
points the whole thing seems nonsense
also I you my biggest takeaway from it
Giannis is on edge like I know that
they're 17 and seven I understand he
just obviously had an unbelievable game
I I guess I had two takeaways one is
this is actually sign of success from
the inseason tournament because the
Pacers and Bucks have like real friction
now you know what I mean they played in
a meaningful game Indiana won and so now
that is like a butting potential rivalry
so I like that part of it I don't think
that happens without the season
tournament obviously LeBron doesn't get
to his fifth ring just one shy of
Michael now with the inseason tournament
but uh also the they Giannis I think I
think the Bucks thought this was going
to be more seamless and I have real
concerns about Milwaukee's ability to
guard anybody obviously Giannis is great
and Dame is very very good still I don't
know if he's great still but I think
that was more of the canary and the coal
mine of all this that Giannis is Maybe
more uneasy than we we've seen him at
this point in the season before yeah I
was really surprised that you could have
done it in with a little bit more
decorum of hey I would like to have that
basketball he's not aware that the
Pacers have a tradition I'm guessing but
I mean he's chasing somebody down as if
somebody has you know punched him
they're just going after a basketball
and Draymond wouldn't even at the game
so that's not going to happen have you
checked in with your dear friend Reggie
Miller about is this a Pacers tradition
you guys are talking about calling JJ
reic JJ you call JJ reic he's just going
to talk about how all sports television
shows suck and how we just need to
dissect what Horn's action is instead
you should call Reggie and ask him well
it's early it's early on the west coast
for Reggie Fair before I ask him that
but this might be a tradition with Rick
carlile's
Pacers that would be well then we need
to call Dirk it's late in Germany see if
he had the tradition going on in Dallas
I don't know call somebody that would
know uh it feels like the Draymond Green
suspended indefinitely is like the
commissioner's exemp list in the NFL so
it felt like a copout to me I want to
see how many games it is because I would
have liked how many games it ends up
being I would have
liked it it felt like once again and now
this I'm gonna sound like an old man
where Adam Silver is taking too soft of
a touch like he's going going through
some things he needs some help all of
that might be true he also three times
his last 26 games has executed various
UFC moves on players on the court and
four times in the last 15 months I Dan
you know how like when they show you hey
here are the the in the last two years
the 40o triple doubles in the NBA and
it's all just Luca and jokic's names on
an eight eight man list if we were to be
like hey in the last two years here are
the four most violent acts in the NBA
just four Draymond things and the I he
even if he's going through things even
if he needs help I personally would have
liked it to say he is suspended for at
least X pardon me x amount of games and
the suspension will be indefinite post
that until he carries out these
benchmarks because I and I don't say
this euphemistically he is by the
literal definition out of control and
one other thing his postgame explanation
does not jive with the punishment the or
the whatever we want to call it the
postgame explanation was I did not mean
to do that that is not if that is if if
we are going to take you at your word
which is very very hard to do then the
help he needs is either acting classes
or some cisic exercises to be more
limber not what they are referring to so
I the whole thing stinks to me and yeah
I feel badly for Steph but I blame the
war the Warriors Dan really prioritized
ring Knight the way I guess the Pacers
prioritize first basket basketballs and
they never punished him for the Jordan
pool thing which derailed not only that
season we that thing's got a long tail D
it might have derailed Draymond it might
have ruined Jordan P's career I I don't
know like the whole thing stinks yeah I
I think it the blame starts with the
Golden State Warriors they have been
enablers and to the highest degree the
fact that you knock out Jordan P you
don't get suspended you get awarded a
4-year $100 million contract Draymond
knows whatever I do during the regular
season okay but you know I'll be there
in the postseason well that's not the
case anymore in the next four years you
have him and that personality before he
takes over for Charles Barkley on
TNT but so a couple things one so let's
talk about the second thing you said
first it am I am I just too you know
reactionary right now to say these
things are greatly hurting his ability
to do exactly that take over for Charles
Barkley on TNT like that Draymond by the
time we get there will the Contemporary
NBA fan when they hear Draymond Green
will they think man one of the greatest
defensive players ever uh the second or
third most important Cog in a true
Dynasty or will they think lunatic and
so I the the to me that is that is more
influx than previously and to your to to
your point that you know but I'll be
there for the playoffs I I'm good in the
playoffs not if you cost your team
making the playoffs like the Warriors
are in real trouble oh no I'm talking
about previous years yes now it's caught
up to them because he's this is his
personality and now all of a sudden you
know they're not going to be there in
May and
June
also I I would be remiss to not I'll
just be totally honest I don't have this
full thought completed and that's you
know risky to ever just go and live with
it but Jordan PS 80 pounds lighter than
him much smaller and then the three guys
in the last year he's attacked are
European players he he doesn't he and
I'm not listen I'm not saying there is
anything intrinsic about European
players but I do think that that would
be an odd statistical coincidence given
the percentage of players that are
European versus otherwise I just don't
ever since he slapped LeBron in the
groin area I haven't seen him do any of
this he shoved Donovan Mitchell from
behind like where's the Draymond Green
you know squaring up with Paul George
where's the Draymond he kicks Stephen
Adams who's a big strong guy but he
kicked him in the groin where are the
instances Draymond just strikes me as
you know at least potentially
fraudulently tough obviously tough
Defender great player and all those
things but it the extracurricular stuff
none of it has seemed like a fair fight
and even if you take the European stuff
outside of it you have sabonis laying on
the ground yeah you have goar not
looking at him and you have nurkic
having no idea this is coming none
whatsoever none of it is you know kind
of a fair fight so to speak yeah he's
cowardly tough cowardly tough yes that's
how I feel uh we're talking to Nick
Wright host of first things first on Fox
Sports One and host of what's right with
Nick Wright on iTunes and YouTube let's
recap your weekend with the Kansas City
Chiefs okay what do you mean what do you
how I how dealt with it yeah you you
recap you recap how you you recap okay
sorry I misunderstood yeah you recap
your weekend with your Che so I do not
believe in blaming the
officials uh and I will not in this case
I understand the anger towards them
though from momes and Andy and everyone
in my opinion including you know
recently I think the commissioner is
missing the anger the anger is not
cadarius Tony was not lined up off sides
the anger was as credit to Dan orlovski
as he pointed out he was lined up
offside six times in that exact spot
throughout the game the next night on
Monday Night Football Jaylen Wadd a
couple times was lined up off sides we
we saw this there is a reason that Andy
had coached
2,172 plays prior to that one it had
never been called because either the
refs don't care care about it or when
they first see it they do give you a
warning and you then adjust and I folks
rolled their eyes at that and the
analogous NFL situation that I would use
is we watch every week football the play
clock get to zero you could take a
screenshot it's at zero the ball is not
snapped but everyone understands for
some weird reason you actually get like
0 minus. 7 Seconds like you get an extra
beat
to snap it if you have been operating
like the that the entire game and then a
team with a minute left the moment it
goes zero you throw the flag and you're
like hey rules are rules I would
understand the frustration and lastly
because there is I think a bit of
misinformation out there because the NBC
broadcast after the game they were like
yeah it was called once two years ago
twice last year but it's been called 11
times this year it's to point of
emphasis this year that's wildly
misleading cuz I looked it up prior to
this week's football it had been called
11 times eight of them were on offensive
linemen in those tush push situations
where lining up a little off sides is a
massive advantage and that is a
different unique circumstance it had
been called three times on wide
receivers all year so I get the
frustration and I also I'm old enough to
remember Tom Brady streaking after
officials into the tunnel on Monday
Night Football like competitive guys can
get fired up and upset so I I'm not mad
at Mahomes about it and I think I think
and the last one left that the Chiefs
will be fine but I it was a tough
circumstance paired with the previous
week when everyone agreed it was pass
interference and the Chiefs took the
high road to a man on yeah I give
Mahomes a hall pass not that he needs
one from me but you know in the moment
this play is erased he's not quite sure
why it's erased uh you know he's angry
there's passion
um I'm not sure why they didn't call it
the other times um the fact that you
don't look over and you check with the
official just so he can give you
acknowledgement uh which he didn't do a
mistake yes it's a total mistake and the
Chiefs have to own it and it is a
symptom of the overall bigger thing that
has plagued them all year which is wide
receiver lack of attention to detail you
know what I mean so that's why and I
should say this just to be fair I think
they the defense had been playing great
after the first couple drives I think
they would have stopped the bills but
that would it wasn't 4 seconds left in
the game it was a minute 15 they would
have been up four so the bills could
have driven down the field and still won
the game so there are other factors
there and yes the Chiefs need to be
sharper about it but this whole the the
immediacy of oh my God it was an obvious
call you have to make that call that's
nonsense that's still I think folks
upset about how the Super Bowl ended who
think the Chiefs owe the league multiple
calls throughout the course of the
Season maybe I understand the chiefs
with the interference at Lambo but you
know there are a couple other things
imagine if Kelsey throws that ball or it
gets knocked down what would we be
talking about in that moment cuz you're
in field goal range right there so he'd
be thrown that b and almost got knocked
down the other part of it that's more
alarming for me is if you watch Tony
first of all you don't need to be all
the way up on the line of scrimmage
you're not going to the end zone he only
went 10 yards and did it down and out
and then he's open and momes doesn't
throw and he gestures back like and then
his head goes down and then he stops and
then Travis has this unbelievable play
he's wide open then he goes into the end
zone the body language with Tony was
more disturbing and and he has not
played well and there's a reason why the
Giants gave up on him so that would be a
bigger issue with that if you look at
him and the body language on that play
he would get credit for being a heads up
play but really it wasn't you don't
think he knew Travis was going to do
that was playing posum oh I'm going to
get
him they're not going to pay attention
to me right now if I look like I'm angry
at my home 5D chess um no I totally
agree with you yeah I mean the and
listen I I will say this I I am shocked
at the amount of revisionist History
that's going on with the Tyreek Hill
trade right now they won the Super Bowl
they were the highest scoring team they
had the league MVP they scored 38 in the
Super Bowl and it allowed them to build
out this defense I would do that trade
again but I would also be lying if I
didn't say I watched Monday Night
Football and watch DeAndre Hopkins be
the best player on the field at various
points
and say that would have been nice like
you know what I mean and he was
available was not crazy expensive they
could have made that work they chose to
want to prioritize the development of
Tony Sky Moore and the kid who I think
is excellent Rashi rice the kid they
drafted this year they wanted them to
get the snaps they wanted them to get
the Reps so they didn't go prioritize an
aging wide receiver that does appear to
be a mistake there's no way around that
it's great to talk to you I miss you I
thought you were mad at me or something
you guys you know you guys haven't had
me on in quite some time I don't know
what's going on um busy I but you're
usually busy like we we you know we try
sometimes and you got a podcast and then
you got other things going on and want
to be find I find a way to do it okay
and it's less about our professional
relationship than our personal
relationship which the last time uh I
text you I was talking about taking you
to dinner and you just responded with a
thumbs up emoji but no date no time no
confirmation so you know it's still just
floating out there in The Ether at some
point I ass but you have to take more of
an initiative not just dinner you have
to say dinner at this restaurant how
does this sound like if you're going to
date somebody you would girlfriend yeah
yeah but you wouldn't go dinner you
would say yeah because I'm not trying to
sleep with you Dan trying to talk sports
and have a bottle of wine with you I I
don't think I need to woo you but maybe
I've misplaced the relationship nothing
wrong with being wooed just saying okay
goodbye all right see you later yeah
that's Nick Wright host of first things
first on Fox Sports One and his podcast
what's right with Nick Wright on iTunes
and YouTube